[Music]
if John Chamberlain sculptures look like
car wrecks that's because in a very real
sense they are Chamberlain would torque
and twist and weld and pound various
auto parts to create the kind of
sculptures that you see here we're in
the minuchin gallery on New York's Upper
East Side which is combined 12 works by
Chamberlain with seven paintings by the
abstract expressionist villain de
Kooning to create the show appropriately
named Chamberlain de Kooning this work
titled gold rose is from 1974 and is on
sale for a hefty 4.5 million dollars and
while you're probably thinking that you
could buy for Bugatti Veyrons and rectum
yourself for that price Chamberlain's
market in comparison with his peers has
been relatively affordable the most
expensive chamber Leonard auction sold
for just 4.7 million dollars the most
expensive de Kooning sold just as
november for more than sixty six million
dollars that's what makes this
combination of art so powerful why is
this with so much less than that for
some background Chamberlain began to
make his metal sculptures in the late
1950s and became famous at least within
the art world fairly quickly but
Chamberland never quite reached the same
level of prominence as his peers why
there's a simple explanation people like
paintings more than sculptures paintings
are more popular because they're easier
to hang easier to transport an easier to
take care of all of which means they're
easier to show off if you look at this
sculpture it actually fits perfectly
within the narrative of abstract
expressionism where someone like Jackson
Pollock would fling paint onto the
canvas this sculpture is like a Pollock
in 3d you can see the expressions of the
artist inflicted on to these fenders on
to these car hoods on to all of this
metal so in a sense this is the 3d
visual real-life embodiment of what the
de Kooning what the Pollack's what a lot
of different contemporaries of John
Chamberlain were doing on a flat surface
and that's why these things are so
valued this is sculpture but this is
abstract expressionism
very tangible form here the galleries
point is that sculpture should be as
highly prized as painting now they just
have to find some deep pocketed
collectors who agree with them
you